a lot of the words you were using their
Peter about sort of you know please
create this creative spark these these
games that you know captivate you in a
certain way I think would you apply that
to no man's sky oh yeah I mean that's
the game that came up next and this is
one that you know piqued our interest
last year at e3 and this it just Wow's
me again to watch the kind of transition
from ground to space to ground and back
again that's it's stunning yeah they did
they did this time what they didn't do
the first time which a lot of people
wanted to see which was the transition
from space back down to terrain and this
game just made too much of a splash
earlier in the year for somebody not to
have picked it up so when it wasn't on
the microsoft stage you kind of thought
there's a pretty good chance that
someone you're going to try and catch
yourself especially because hello games
actually have a much better relationship
with Sony than they do with with
Microsoft they got burned pretty bad on
em Joe Danger what xbox who wanted
nothing to do with them and they've
released every game they made since
first on a sony platform so this makes
sense so it's a timed exclusive on
playstation 4 and yeah it looks gorgeous
if we can show that part where where the
were the it streams in from the space
into the the terrain of the second
planet like that was really something
else it looks gorgeous they've shown a
lot more now in terms of the and in
terms of the animals in terms of the
settings at the start it looked like
very scenic for the first trailer all
that stuff but and this is this is right
right here this is incredible and yet
you just you see the the spires
populating you see some foliage start to
populate in it like about this level oof
oh yeah and then you're down there
that's pretty amazing right and all this
stuff is like Annie said Sean Murray
representing the great county of
waterford ireland and shows said as well
that you'll start on your own planet
like you will be alone and you will find
other people and i think there's some
really powerful exploration gonna happen
and you maybe shoot them a little bit
which is still a mystery to me why this
would happen it's your turf man i
discovered that dinosaur get it out of
here instead of shock
you